[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER:
Welcome, everyone.
Welcome back to
theory of computation.
And just to recap
where we are, we
have been looking at
time complexity and space
complexity.
And we just finished
proving what
are called the hierarchy
theorems, which, in a nutshell,
basically say that, if you
allow the computational model
to have a little bit more
resource, a little bit
more time, a little
bit more space, then
you can do more things
with certain conditions.
So we proved that last time.
It was a proof, basically,
by a diagonalization.
I don't know if you recognized
the diagonalization there,
but when you're encoding
a machine by an input
and then basically running all
possible different machines,
that's essentially
a diagonalization.
So today, we're going
to build on that work
to give an example
of what we call
a natural intractable problem.
We'll say a bit more
about what that means.
And then, we're going to
talk about something which
is a different topic,
but nevertheless related,
having to do with oracles and
methods which may or may not
work to solve the P versus NP
problem, which, of course, is
a big open problem in the field.
OK.
So the time and space
hierarchy theorems--
because we're going to
be using those today--
they say that if you give a
little bit more space here-- so
for space constructible
functions, functions
that you can actually compute
within the amount of space
that they specify, you can
show that the things that you
can do in that much space
is probably larger than what
you can do in less space.
And you can prove a similar
slightly weaker fact
about the time
complexity classes.
So what that means is that
these classes form a hierarchy.
So as you add more
time, or let's
say, in this case, space,
from n squared, to n cubed,
to n to the 4th, you get
larger and larger classes,
which I'm kind illustrating
here by putting a dot there,
which shows that
there's something
that we know that's
new in those classes
as you go up these
different bounds.
And this is going to be
true for space complexity
and it's also going to be
true for time complexity.
And one of the corollaries
that we pointed out last time
is that, PSPACE is a-- properly
includes non-deterministic log
space, NL.
So NL is a proper
subset of PSPACE.
So there's stuff in
PSPACE that is not in NL.
And remember this notation
here, this means proper subset.
One of the things that--
a follow-on corollary that
we didn't mention last time,
but that's something
that you should know,
is that the TQBF problem, our
PSPACE based complete problem,
is an example of a problem
that's in PSPACE, obviously,
but we know it's also not in NL.
And in order to get
that conclusion,
you have to look, again, at
the proof that TQBF is PSPACE
complete, and observe that
the reductions that we gave
in that proof can be carried
out not only in polynomial time,
but they can be carried
out in log space.
And therefore, if TQBF
turned out to go down to NL,
then because
everything in PSPACE
is log space reducible to TQBF,
that would bring all of PSPACE
down to NL.
But that we just
proved is not the case.
So therefore, TQBF
could not be in NL.
OK, and we're going to be
using that kind of reasoning
again in this lecture.
So just a quick check-in.
These are a few,
more or less easy,
maybe more or less
tricky, follow-ons
that you can conclude from
the time and space hierarchy
theorems plus some
of the other things
we've proven along the way.
And so just as a check of
your understanding, maybe
these a little bit
on the tricky side,
so you have to read
them carefully.
Which of these are known to
be true based on the material
that we've presented?
And this is also
just material that's
the facts that we know to be
true in complexity theory.
So let me launch that poll.
And just check off the
ones that we can prove.
Hmm.
OK.
I'm going to close it down.
So please answer quickly
if you're going to.
OK, 1, 2, 3, end.
OK.
Well, the two leading
candidates are correct.
And the two that are
the laggards here
are, in fact, the ones
that are not true.
So A and D are not true,
based on what we know.
And B and C are true.
So let's understand,
first of all, A, we
know it's false because 2 to
the n plus 1 is just 2 times 2
to the n.
And so these two bounds differ
only by a constant factor.
And so in fact, they're
the same complexity class.
And so you don't get
proper containment for A.
So that one we
absolutely know is false.
D, well, if we could
prove that, then we
would have solved
the famous problem,
because we don't know
whether even P equals PSPACE.
So if P equals PSPACE,
then certainly PSPACE
would equal NP, which
is in between the two.
And so we don't
know how to prove
PSPACE is different
from NP, that's
based on the current state
of knowledge of the field.
So this would not
be something that we
know to be true based on
what things that we've said.
Now, B follows directly from
the time hierarchy theorem,
because 2 to the 2n is
the square of 2 to the n.
And that is, asymptotically,
a significantly larger bound.
And so you can prove that
time 2 the n is properly
contains time 2 the n.
C is a little trickier
because you need
to remember Savitch's theorem.
Savitch's theorem
applies to space.
But you also need to
remember that what
you can do in time, in
non-deterministic time
n squared, you can also do
in non-deterministic space
n squared, which,
then, in turn, you
can do in deterministic space
n to the 4th, which is properly
contained within
space n to the 5th.
So you can prove
that PSPACE properly
contains non-deterministic
time n squared.
OK, just a bunch of
containments there.
A and C are perhaps, in a
sense, it may be the most tricky
of this group.
OK.
So let's move on.
So we're going to introduce,
today, two new classes.
And actually, I want
to go back to here.
What are we going to
be trying to accomplish
in today's lecture?
So we're going to be looking
at provable intractability.
So a problem being intractable
for us means it's outside of P.
So we can't solve it
in polynomial time.
For our perspective,
we're going to call that
an intractable problem.
Now, this problem over here,
that's sitting in time 2 the n,
but not in smaller classes, so
this is an intractable problem.
That's outside of
P. But this example
of a language, if you remember
how the time hierarchy
theorem or the space
hierarchy theorem
was proved, basically,
this language itself is not
an interesting language
for other than the purpose
that it serves, to be in that
class and not in a lower class.
But it's not a language that
anyone would care about.
And it's not even a language
that is easy to describe.
It's just the language that
some Turing machine decides,
where that Turing
machine is especially
designed to have the
property that its language is
at a particular
complexity level.
But otherwise, there's no nice
description of that language.
It's not like a to
the n, b to the n,
or some equivalence of 2
dfa's or something like that.
So I would say that that
language is, in a sense,
it serves its purpose, but it's
not a natural language that you
really care about.
So one one of the goals
of today's lecture
is to give an example
of a natural language,
a naturally-occurring
language, in a sense, that's
easy to describe, where you
can prove that that language is
intractable, is
actually outside of P.
So that's a bit of
motivation where we're going.
So along the way, we're
going to introduce
these exponential complexity
classes, exponential time
and exponential space,
which are exponentially
bigger than polynomial time
and polynomial space classes.
So it's 2 to the n to
the k in both cases.
2 to a polynomial.
And the first five
of these classes, L
through PSPACE
we've already seen,
and exponential time
and exponential space
extend the containments
that we've already seen.
So you have to double check that
you understand why PSPACE is
a subset of exponential time.
But that's because
that, as we showed,
going from space to
time, you can do that
with an exponential increase.
That's the cost
of the simulation.
And going from
time to space, you
don't need any increase at all.
Anything that you can do in
a certain amount of time,
you can do in that much space.
So anything you can do in
a certain amount of space,
you can also do in exponentially
more amount of time.
OK, so those were
simple theorems
that we proved right
at the very beginning.
Now, the hierarchy
theorems allow
us to conclude some separations
among these classes.
So we already looked at
this one, NL versus PSPACE.
And we saw that because NL
is, by Savitch's theorem,
in deterministic log squared
space, which is properly
contained in
polynomial space, you
get a separation between
those two classes, provably.
And for similar reasons,
polynomial space
to exponential
space, you're going
to get a separation from
the space hierarchy theorem.
And polynomial time
to exponential time,
you get a provable
separation by virtue
of the hierarchy theorem.
Now we're going to
define complete problems
for these two classes,
exponential time
and exponential space.
So we have exponential
time complete.
It's going to be analogous
to what we showed before,
which is that it's a
member of exponential time.
And every problem in exponential
time is reducible to it,
let's say, in polynomial
time, though it's not
going to really turn
out to be matter.
It could be in log space.
Some simple method of
doing the reduction
is going to be good enough.
Let's say polynomial time
is the typical definition.
And the same thing for
exponential space complete.
We'll say it's exponential
space complete,
if it's an exponential space.
And anything else
in exponential space
is polynomial time
reducible to it.
OK.
But the important thing
is that if something
is exponential
time complete, you
know it's outside of P, for
the same reasons we've now
seen several times.
Namely, that if an exponential
time complete problem ended up
being in P, then
because everything
else in exponential time is
reducible to the complete
problem, they
would also be in P.
And so exponential time
and P would be equal.
But we just said they're not
equal because of the hierarchy
theorem.
So the logic is the hierarchy
theorem separates the class,
and then the complete problem
inherits the difficulty
of the larger class.
So the complete problem cannot
be any lower than the other
problems in the class, because
they're all reducible to it.
So the same thing is going to
be true for an exponential space
complete problem.
Can't be even in PSPACE because
exponential space and PSPACE
are different.
And if it's not in PSPACE,
it's not going to be in P.
And so in both cases, if
you have a problem that's
complete for exponential
space or exponential time,
we know that those
problems are intractable.
And our strategy,
then, for giving
a natural intractable
problem is to show
it's complete for
one of these classes.
And it's actually
going to turn out
to be an exponential space
complete problem that we're
going to give as our example.
OK, so that is the plan.
I think it's a good time to--
let's just take a
few questions here
to make sure we're all on the
same page as what we're doing.
So let me just read.
I got a couple of
questions already in here.
So this is a little
bit of a side
comment that somebody-- that's
an interesting question.
Basically, is it
possible that we may not
be able to prove, solve
the P versus NP problem,
that it's not a problem
that one can answer
from the basic axioms
of mathematics,
if I'm interpreting
the question correctly.
There are certain
problems in mathematics--
and I think I,
perhaps, I mentioned
earlier in the term, the
problem of whether there
is a set whose size is
in between the integers
and the real numbers.
We know the real numbers
are larger in size
than the integers.
That was our first example
of a diagonalization.
And is there a problem of size
strictly in between the two?
Bigger than the integers,
smaller than the real numbers.
So that's a problem that
was posed a long time ago.
It was one of
Hilbert's problems.
And was eventually
shown to be unanswerable
using the basic
axioms of mathematics.
So the question is,
maybe P versus NP
is in the same category.
Could be.
That could be true of
any unsolved problems
in mathematics.
But at least our
experience has shown
that the kinds of problems
that, at least, have been shown
to be unsolvable from
mathematical axioms
tend to involve
infinities and very large
things, things that are very
far from our intuitions.
And something as down to earth
as P versus NP, at least,
it would be very
surprising to me
if that turned out
to be unanswerable
using our mathematical axioms.
But, who knows?
Oh, this is another
good question.
Do the time and space
hierarchy theorems
have non-deterministic variants?
Yes, they do.
They're much harder
to prove, however,
and we're not going
to cover that.
But you can also prove that
non-deterministic time, n cubed
properly includes
non-deterministic time
n squared.
You're not going to be
responsible for that.
Don't worry.
If you try to
actually prove that,
you'll see the diagonalization
doesn't directly work.
And so you have to
do something fancier.
People are asking about which
reduction method to use.
Again, the kinds of
reductions that we encounter
are always very simple.
So we're just going to be
working with very weak notions
of reductions.
Not interesting yet, generally,
to consider powerful kinds
of reductions like polynomial
exponential time reductions
or things like that.
So it's just not something that
people really think about much.
I mean, I can talk about
it at length offline.
But let's just assume that
our reduction strength
is something very low.
Log space is going
to be good enough
to do all of the
reductions in this class.
OK, so let's move on, then.
So here is the
problem that we're
going to spend the
next 20 minutes
or so proving to be
exponential space complete.
I have got to do a little
introduction first.
So this is not the problem, but
this is related to the problem.
So the problem of testing
if two regular expressions
are equivalent.
Write down to
regular expressions,
do they generate
the same language?
So that problem actually
turns out to be in PSPACE.
So it's not going to be
exponential space complete.
It's actually in PSPACE.
I don't think we're
going to have--
I thought about presenting
it in the lecture.
It's not that hard to show.
But it just took too much
time and doesn't really
introduce new methods.
It's a good exercise, actually,
using Savitch's theorem.
But maybe we'll do
it in recitation,
or if the lecture
miraculously ends earlier,
I'll do it at the end.
But I don't think
we'll have time.
But that's a setup for
the intractable problem
that we're going to talk
about, which is very related.
Now, OK, before
we get to that, so
if I have a regular
expression, I'm
going to enhance our regular
expression in one simple way,
by allowing exponents
or exponentiation.
And that means if I have
a regular expression R,
I can write R to the k to mean
R concatenated with itself k
times.
We've been sort of informally
using that all the way along
anyway, like when we talk
about 0 to the k, 1 to the k.
So if we're going to
formally allow that
when we write down regular
expressions, in some cases,
that might allow the
regular expression
to be much smaller,
especially if we're
writing down k in binary.
Because I can write R to
the million with just a few
symbols if I have
exponentiation.
But if I don't have
exponentiation,
then I have to
write R concatenated
with R out a million
times, and I get a much,
much longer, an exponentially
longer expression
if I don't have that exponent
as a way of describing
regular expressions.
And that's going to
make a big difference.
So now, the equivalence problem
for regular expressions with
exponentiation-- that's what
that little up arrow means,
what it signifies--
now I'm giving you two
regular expressions.
But they're allowed to
have the exponentiation
operation in addition to the
standard regular operations.
So now, testing whether two of
these regular expressions that
have exponentiation,
that problem
turns out to be
exponential space complete.
So here's the equivalence
problem for regular expressions
with exponentiation.
That's an exponential
space complete problem.
And as we pointed out,
that means this problem
is provably intractable.
So there's just no
way, in general,
to solve that problem
in polynomial time.
That's proven, that's known.
So we're going to go
through the reduction.
I think it's going to be our
last reduction of the term,
of proving problems
complete for some class.
But each one of those has
their own kind of thing
that makes it special.
So first of all, we have to show
that it's in exponential space.
That's really going to
rely on this other fact
that we didn't prove.
So I'm going to go
over that very quickly.
But the interesting part
is doing the reduction.
So if I have something
in exponential space
that I can show
that I can reduce it
to the equivalence problem
for regular expressions
with exponentiation.
OK, so quickly arguing
part one that we're
in exponential space,
basically, what you do
is you take your two
regular expressions
that you want to test to
see if they're equivalent,
but now they have
exponentiation.
And as a first step, you get
rid of the exponentiation.
You just expand things out
by repeating the parts that
have the exponents.
And of course, as I
said, that's going
to make the expression
themselves exponentially
bigger.
But now, you run
the PSPACE algorithm
on those two exponentially
larger expressions.
So the input that the
PSPACE algorithm is now
exponential in the
original input size,
but it's PSPACE in
that enlarged input.
So that's going to give
you an exponential space
algorithm in the original input
size, because you expanded
it to become
exponentially bigger,
and then you run the PSPACE
algorithm on that expanded
problem.
So that gives you an
exponential space algorithm
for this problem.
But now, what
we're going to do--
the interesting part
is the reduction.
So given some language and
exponential space, say,
decided by some Turing machine
in that amount of space,
2 to the n to the k, we're going
to give a reduction that maps a
to this equivalence problem.
Got it?
That is the plan.
So let's make sure we're
all together on the plan
before we go ahead and
carry out that plan.
We just sort of
set things up here,
in a sense, for what
we're going to be doing.
So feel free to ask a
question on just the plan.
It's going to get technical.
Because, as doing these
reductions always is,
there's a simulation
involved, and you
have to kind of describe that
simulation in its own way.
So now, we're going
to be simulating,
in a certain sense,
M on w, the decider
for this exponential
space, problem A,
we're going to take
M on w and we're
going to somehow have to express
the fact that M accepts w using
this equivalence problem
for regular expressions
with exponentiation.
So no questions?
Why don't we move on?
I have three slides on this,
but they're kind of dense,
I'm sorry to say.
So here is the plan as usual.
We're going to map A with
a polynomial time reduction
to the equivalence problem
for regular expressions
with exponentiation.
So that means we're going to
have to take an input, which
may or may not be in A, and
produce two regular expressions
with exponentiation, which are
going to be equivalent when
w is in A. Or when M accepts w.
So it's going to be, as
these things always are,
these are going to be in
terms of the computation
history for M under w.
But in this case,
it's going to turn out
to be convenient to work with
the rejecting computation
history for M on w.
So remember, now we
have a Turing machine M.
It's a decider, so that
means it always holds--
for the strings in the language,
it ends up at a Q accept state,
for things not in the language,
it ends up at a Q reject state.
So a rejecting
computation history
is the sequence
of configurations
the machine goes through
from the start configuration
until it ends up
at a configuration
with a reject state, a
rejecting configuration.
And we're going to make
a regular expression that
describes all strings
except for that one.
It's going to avoid describing
a rejecting computation
history for M on w.
Otherwise, it's going to
describe all possible strings.
Now, if M does not
reject w, so there
is no rejecting
computation history--
namely, M accepts w, by the way.
So if M accepts w,
does not reject w,
it does not have a rejecting
computation history,
what is R1 describing?
Well, it's describing,
in that case, everything,
because there is no rejecting
computation history.
So it's describing every
other string besides.
So that means it's describing
all strings, if there
is no rejecting computation
history in the case
that M accepts w.
So what does that suggest
we should use for R2?
R2 is going to be the
regular expression that
just generates all strings.
So we'll be testing whether R1
generates all strings or not,
which is the same as saying
does M accept w or not.
So R2 is going to be--
I would like to say sigma
star, but sigma is really
the input to M, and gamma
is the tape alphabet for M.
So we have a lot of Greek
letters to play with,
so we're going to use
delta for the alphabet
that we write the
computation histories in.
If you want to get reminded what
that delta is, a computation
history can have a tape
alphabet symbol for M,
it can have a
state symbol for M,
or it can have a
delimiter pound--
hashtag.
So it's either a
capital delta alphabet
is a tape alphabet symbol, or
state, something representing
a state symbol, or a hashtag.
That's just delta.
So don't get-- I always
feel bad if somebody
gets confused by
something that's
supposed to be very simple.
Don't get confused
by delta star.
This is just all
possible strings
over the alphabet delta.
OK, so what does R1--
so my job is to do R1.
R2, I already told you.
R1 now has to describe
all those strings
except for the rejecting
computation history.
So everything that fails to be a
rejecting computation history--
so it fails either
because it started wrong,
or it ended wrong, or it's
wrong somewhere in the middle.
And by wrong I mean, it
fails to correctly describe
the way the machine operates
if it's ending up rejecting w.
All right.
So I'm going to describe
all those possible strings
by breaking it down into
those three categories.
Starts wrong, ends wrong,
or somewhere computes
wrong along the way.
OK.
So rejecting computation history
looks something like this.
Here's the start configuration
as we usually envision it.
It's a start state looking at
the first symbol of the input,
and there's the
rest of the input.
So let me just write this out.
This is a rejecting
computation history now.
So the first configuration,
the second one,
and so on and so on, until
we end up at a rejecting
computation-- rejecting
configuration.
Now, for convenience,
I'm going to insist
that all of these configurations
are the same length.
It's going to make my life
easier in doing the proof.
But why can I do that?
Well, I'm just
going to take them--
you know, because usually you
think of the configurations,
they start small because they're
just basically of length n,
but this is using
exponential space,
they're getting
longer and longer.
Let's just pair them
all out with blanks
so that they're
all the same size.
So as I've indicated
over here, we're
adding in a bunch of blanks.
It's going to be a
lot of blanks here,
to make sure they all
have length 2 to the n
to the k, which is the maximum
size of a configuration
when you have that much space.
I'm going to construct-- so
basically, that's my job.
I'm going to construct
R1 so that it
generates all those strings.
I wrote a little box around
that thing I'm trying to--
that's my to do.
It's going to help me
in the coming slides
because they're a
little bit dense.
When I'm going to draw this
sort of reddish, pinkish box
around something,
that means that I'm
going to try to describe all
strings except for that one.
I want to avoid
describing that one,
because that's the rejecting
computation history,
but I want to describe
everything else.
That's my wish.
So here's a check in
before we move forward.
But we can also--
maybe we should just
take some questions, even
before we launch the check in.
How are we doing here?
So, is our one describing--
well, R1 is a
regular expression.
Over here, we're
talking about a--
this is just an ordinary
computation history,
but it ends with a reject.
That's all.
A rejecting computation
history is just one that's
a little different at the end.
The machine just ended up
rejecting instead of accepting.
Otherwise everything has to
be spelled out in accordance
with the rules of the machine
and the start configuration.
Yeah, we were assuming
one rejecting state.
Yeah, that's the way we
actually define Turing machines
in the first place.
But, who's arguing.
Yeah, there's one reject state.
We're all
deterministic, correct.
Why do we need the padding?
Because I want to make these
all the same size, all of these
configurations.
That's going to help
me later in terms
of describing the invalid
configurations, the ones that
are not legal configurations,
legal rejecting configurations.
So just simply a
matter of convenience,
but just accept it for now.
I just want all of
those configurations
to be the same length in my
rejecting computation history.
Otherwise I'm not going to--
I'm just coding that
rejecting computation history
in this particular way.
So people are asking about
the details of bad start.
That's yet to come.
I have two more slides on this.
So I'll tell you about how
we're going to do those.
So R bad-start-- that's a good
question-- is R bad-start all--
these are all the strings
that don't start this way.
We'll see it in a second.
But R bad-start are all the
things that don't start with
the--
they start bad.
They're not starting with
the start configuration.
They're starting
with some other junk.
Do we need only one rejecting
computation history?
What about the other ones?
This is a deterministic machine,
so there's only going to be--
if I prescribe the
lengths as I've done,
there's going to be only one
rejecting computation history.
Because it's
deterministic, everything
is going to be forced
from the beginning.
Should R1 be the
not of those three?
No.
R1 is describing
all of the strings
except, except this one string.
So I'm capturing all the
different possible ways
a string could fail
to be the string.
It could start wrong.
Could be wrong along
the middle somewhere.
So I have to union
them together.
Because I'm describing--
as I always believe,
negations are the most
confusing thing to everybody,
including me.
So we're describing
all the things
that are not this string.
We're trying to stay
away from that one.
We want to describe
everything else.
All right, I think I'd
better move on here.
We've got a lot of questions.
Talk to the TAs.
All right, check in.
How big is this rejecting
computation history anyway?
Interesting.
There's a lesson here.
I got a big burst of answers
right at the very beginning.
All wrong.
But then the bright--
the people who took a little
bit more time to think
started getting the
right answer, which is--
let's look.
We've got a close election here
folks, so now I have to report.
Hope we don't have
to do a recount.
OK, come on guys.
Answer up.
10 seconds.
This is not super hard.
Stop the count.
Yeah, I think we'd better stop
at this, we're on the edge.
OK, 3 seconds.
End polling.
Share results.
The correct answer
is, in fact, c.
Why is that?
Because each configuration
is 2 to the n to the k.
So that's how much space the
machine has, exponential space.
But the amount of time,
which is each one--
the number of
configurations is going
to be the amount of
time that's used.
It's going to be exponentially
more even than that.
So it's going to be 2 to
the 2 to the n of the k,
is how many steps
the machine can run.
And that's going to be how long
the computation history could
be.
So it's a very long thing.
And when you think about
it, the regular expression
we are generating,
how big is that?
The regular expression--
again, a lot
of people playing
off my comments here.
Were the votes legal or not?
OK.
Let's focus here.
So this is doubly
exponentially large.
How big is the
regular expression
that we're generating?
Well that has to be
produced in polynomial time,
so it's only polynomially big.
So we have this little teensy
weensy, relatively speaking,
regular expression,
which is only n to the k.
It's having to
describe all strings
except for this particular
string, which is 2 to the 2
to the n to the k.
So in a sense,
this string that is
related to that
regular expression
is doubly exponentially
larger than that.
And that kind of presents
some of the challenge
in doing the reduction,
in constructing
that regular expression.
So let's move on
and start doing--
this is the hard stuff.
Here is the bad start,
which is challenging enough.
Even this little piece is going
to be a little bit challenging
to describe.
Just rewriting from
the previous slide.
So we're trying
to make R1, which
is generating all the
strings except the rejecting
computation history for M on w.
It's in those three parts.
Right now I'm describing
the bad start piece.
So that's going to
describe all strings that
don't start with this C1.
So let me write that out here.
This is going to
generate all strings that
don't start with C start or
C1, which is as specified.
Looks like this.
So any string that doesn't start
with these symbols, doesn't
start exactly like
this, should be
described by bad start,
that regular expression.
So that, in itself, is going
to be further subdivided.
And the reason for that is
not that hard to understand.
I'm going to--
bad start is going
to accomplish its
goal by saying, well,
anything that doesn't
start this way either
doesn't start with a q0,
or doesn't or doesn't
have a w1 in the next
place, or doesn't
have a w2 in the next place.
Or somewhere along the
way, it has a wrong symbol.
Each one of these guys
is going to be about one
of those symbols being wrong
in some particular place.
So I'm going to show you
what those look like.
So right now, I'm going
to focus my attention
on describing all strings
except for this one.
All strings that start with
something except for this one.
So just remember,
delta is the alphabet
for the competition histories.
And some notation here,
delta sub epsilon,
we've seen this
before, is you're
going to add in epsilon as
an allowed thing for delta.
So it's all the
symbols, or epsilon, now
thought of as a set here.
And furthermore, it's going to
be convenient to talk about all
of the symbols in delta,
except for some symbol.
So like at the
very beginning, q0.
I want to talk about all of the
symbols except for q0 symbol.
Because that's what
I'm going to be
using to start off R bad-start.
It's going to be
anything except for q0.
So let's just see
how that looks.
So here is S0, the very
first part of our bad start.
It's going to say--
I'm trying to color the
active ingredient here
in the pink color.
So delta, with q0 removed,
followed by anything.
So this little
regular expression
here describes all strings
that don't start with a q0,
as I'm indicating over here.
All strings that
don't start with a q0
is what as S0 describes.
You have to understand
that, because it's just
going to build up from there.
So what do we want
to say for S1?
What's going to be
all strings that don't
have w1 in the second place?
So I'm going to
write that over here.
S1 is anything in
the first place--
I mean, if the first place
was wrong, S0 took care of it.
So I'm just going to
keep my life simple.
All I want to do is
describe all of the places
where the second
symbol is wrong.
Namely, it's not w1.
So anything in the
first place, something
besides w1 in the next place,
and then anything at all
afterward.
Those are all strings
that don't have--
[AUDIO CUTS]
So I'll write it
over here like that.
Now S2 similarly is going to
d since I have exponentiation,
let's use that for convenience.
Delta delta, or
just delta squared.
So anything in the first two
places, then not w2, and then
the next place,
and then anything.
So that's going to
capture this part.
So this is what
these S's do, and you
can sort of get the idea.
So dot, dot, dot.
This Sn is going to
describe everything
except for wn in
that location, which
is going to be the n plus
first location, actually.
And now I have to continue
on doing that for the blanks.
So now, if you think
with me, let's just
take a look how that could go.
The next symbol, which is
skipping over the n plus 1
that I've already
taken care of, I
want to say it's not a
blank symbol in this very
first location after the input.
So again, I'm
describing these non--
these strings which are not
the start configuration.
It could fail because
there's not a blank where
there's supposed to be a blank.
Suppose I do that for
each one of these guys.
That would work.
But.
But what?
Think.
This is actually not going
to be a good solution for us.
Because there are exponentially
many blanks over here.
This is a hugely
long configuration.
And so there's
exponentially many blanks.
If I do it this way, I'm going
to end up with an exponentially
large regular expression.
And that's not doable
in polynomial time.
So I have a more complicated
way of getting the same effect.
Which is-- I don't
really expect you
to fully parse
through this right
now, in real time in lecture,
but let me try to help you.
What I'm going to do is skip
over these first initial n
plus 1 places, and
then a variable number
of places, which is indicated
by the next piece here.
And the way that works is--
these are all
strings of length n
plus 1 through the end
of the configuration.
And to understand that,
it's almost a little
too technical to even
try, but let's see.
If I put delta to the 7,
that's all strings of length 7.
But if I put delta
sub epsilon to the 7,
if you think about
what that means,
that's all strings of
length between 0 and 7.
Because I can either
have it as epsilon
as my variable or a
symbol from delta.
And so that's what
I'm doing over here.
I'm getting a variable length
space, spacer of deltas,
that are going to then end
up at a certain location--
I'm going to say at that place.
Then I have a non-blank.
Because all I need
to do is describe
the strings that fail to have a
blank somewhere in this range.
So we've got to sort
have a variable spacer
out to that spot, where
that missing blank might be.
So that's what this describes.
If you didn't get
that, don't worry.
That is a technical
point and you can
try to think about it offline.
And then at the very end, I'm
going to describe what happens.
Describe the strings
that fail to have
a hashtag in that location.
It's how I describe all
strings that don't start right.
That's a lot of work, just
to do that little piece.
Fortunately, the next two
pieces are easier, surprisingly.
You can jump in with a
question, but maybe I
should move, push on.
So now I'm going to describe the
bad move and bad reject pieces.
And bad reject
generates all strings
that don't contain
the q reject symbol.
So that's going to
certainly describe
all of the strings that
don't end correctly.
And that's just simply
the delta with the q
reject symbol removed, and
then any string of those.
That's all strings that
don't have q reject.
So that's going to
describe all strings that
don't end with a q reject,
plus some other junk
strings along the way.
But that's all that's
never a problem,
to put in other strings
that you might be capturing
in some other part of
the regular expression
that you know are bad strings.
You just want to make sure you
don't put in that one uniquely
good string, which is
the rejecting computation
history, good string.
And lastly, we're
going to use the notion
of the neighborhoods.
You might think this
is the hardest part,
but in fact not that hard.
So these are all
of the strings that
have somewhere along the
way a violation according
to M's rules.
You want to describe
all of those as well.
I'm going to do that in
terms of the neighborhoods.
But the neighborhoods are
going to be stretched out.
We don't have a tableau
anymore, so they're not
so easily visualizable,
but it's the same idea,
the neighborhood.
So this is abc and def.
But now it's an
illegal neighborhood.
def does not follow from abc.
If all the
neighborhoods are legal,
then the whole computation
is a legitimate computation,
provided it starts
and ends correctly.
So if it's not a
legitimate computation,
there's got to be an illegal
neighborhood somewhere.
And I'm going to just
describe all strings that
have an illegal neighborhood.
And the interesting part is
that you have to describe--
you have to place that
separator between abc and def.
So this is another place where
we're going to critically use
the exponentiation, and the fact
that all of the configurations
are the same length.
That's what we're using there.
We know exactly how
far apart the bottom
of the 2 by 3 neighborhood
is from the top of the 2
by 3 neighborhood.
So we're going to take a
union over all illegal 2
by 3 neighborhoods.
Neighborhood settings,
I should say.
And there's only a fixed number
of those, for the same reason
that we had in the
Cook-Levin theorem.
There's a fixed number of those,
depending upon the machine.
And now we're going
to have, say, we're
going to start with anything.
Here's the top of
the neighborhood.
Here is the separator
that separates the top
from the bottom in the two
consecutive configurations,
here's Ci going C i plus 1
inside my computation history.
And then after that
separator, I put
in the second part of the
neighborhood, which is the def.
You have to really be
comfortable with the way we've
been presenting these
other reductions up
till now, to really get this.
Anyway, I think
we're at the break.
So we can just take
questions during the break,
if you have any.
And I will, otherwise,
see you in five minutes.
In my description back here--
let me just take this off.
For bad reject, it looks like
I'm doing kind of overkill,
and maybe doing
something wrong here.
I'm describing all strings that
don't have a reject anywhere.
But as long as I don't describe
the legitimate rejecting
computation history, I do
describe all strings that
don't end correctly, I'm good.
I could go through more
effort to make sure
that I'm only describing the
very last configuration here
as not having the reject.
But that would
just be more work,
and I don't need
to do that work.
So maybe it would be
good just to understand
why this is sufficient,
what I've described here,
and it's not going to
cause me any problems.
I'm getting a note from
one of my TAs, Thomas,
saying that the
notion "bad" perhaps
is confusing, because bad
sounds like rejecting.
Yes.
I mean bad in the sense of not
describing a legal computation
history.
If you can think
of another name,
I'm happy to switch
that for future years.
Too late for now.
But, yeah.
I don't mean that rejecting,
I mean that it's--
well, I don't know
what the right term is.
Illegal?
Or-- I'm not sure what a good--
How are the neighborhoods
defined here?
What is the tableau here?
I think you do need to think
about it after lecture.
But the tableau, you
can think of the tableau
now here just
written out linearly.
There are all of the
rows now, instead of
nicely organized into a table.
They just appear
consecutively, because I'm just
trying to describe--
I need to do it to
describe a string,
whether my regular
expression doesn't really
make sense to think about.
I mean you can fold it up
into a tableau, if you like.
And then abc and
def will line up.
But here, if you think about
them written consecutively,
this is exactly how far
apart they end up being.
Are there only polynomially
many illegal neighborhoods?
That's why I kind
of corrected myself.
It's not illegal
neighborhoods that we're
talking-- because the number of
neighborhoods in this picture
is vast.
But the number of
neighborhood settings,
the way to set these
values to abc, def.
I mean these are
symbols that can
appear in a configuration
of the machine.
There's only a fixed number of
symbols that can appear here,
that depend upon the
definition of the machine.
So it's not only polynomial.
There's a constant number
of these things, that
only depends on the machine.
So you have to think
about what's going on.
There's a lot-- this
is a lot on the slide.
Bad history for reject.
It's a bad history
for rejecting,
somebody's suggesting.
Yeah, it's a bad history.
Fake news.
Maybe we should be fake.
Fake would be a good term.
No, that's not so good.
I don't know.
Yeah, 2 by 3.
The reason 2 by
3, is the right--
Somebody's asking why 2 by 3.
2 by 3 is exactly
the size you need
to say that, if all the
2 by 3 neighborhoods
are correct everywhere in
the computation history,
then the whole
history is going to be
consistent with the
rules of M. It's
going to be a legal
representation of a computation
of M.
So if the string, which
is allegedly a computation
history, has a bad
neighborhood somewhere,
bad 2 by 3 neighborhood
somewhere, then--
well if it's not a legal
computation history,
it's got to have a
bad neighborhood, 2
by 3 neighborhood somewhere.
OK, let's move on.
Because I think we're
out of time here.
Our timer is up.
We're going to shift
gears now anyway.
So if you got a little
lost in the previous proof,
we're going to talk about
something different.
And in some ways,
a little bit, I
think a little lighter,
a little less technical.
And that's about oracles.
What are oracles?
Oracles are a simple thing.
But they are a useful concept
for a number of reasons.
Especially because
they're going to tell us
something interesting about
methods, which may or may not
be useful for proving
the P versus NP question,
when someday somebody
hopefully does that.
What is an oracle?
An oracle is free
information you're
going to give to a
Turing machine, which
might affect the difficulty
of solving problems.
And the way we're going to
represent that free information
is, we're going to allow
the Turing machine to test
membership in some
specified language,
without charging for
the work involved.
I'm going to allow you have any
language at all, some language
A. And say a Turing machine
with an oracle for A
is written this way, M
with a superscript A. It's
a machine that has a black
box that can answer questions.
Is some string, which
the machine can choose,
in A or not?
And it gets that answer in one
step, effectively for free.
So you can imagine, depending
upon the language that you're
providing to the machine,
that may or may not be useful.
For example, suppose I give you
an oracle for the SAT language.
That can be very useful.
It could be very useful for
deciding SAT, for example.
Because now you don't have to
go through a brute force search
to solve SAT.
You just ask the oracle.
And the oracle is going to
say, yes it's satisfiable,
or no it's not satisfiable.
But you can use that to solve
other languages too, quickly.
Because anything that you can
do in NP, you can reduce to SAT.
So you can convert it to a SAT
question, which you can then
ship up to the oracle,
and the oracle is
going to tell you the answer.
The word "oracle" already sort
of conveys something magical.
We're not really
going to be concerned
with the operation of the
oracle, so don't ask me
how does the oracle work, or
what does it correspond to
in reality.
It doesn't.
It's just a mathematical
device which
provides this free information
to the Turing machine, which
enables it to compute
certain things.
It turns out to be
a useful concept.
It's used in cryptography,
where you might imagine
the oracle could provide
the factors to some number,
or the password to some
system or something.
Free information.
And then what can
you do with that?
So this is a notion that
comes up in other places.
If we have an oracle, we can
think of all of the things
that you can compute
in polynomial time
relative to that oracle.
So that's what we--
the terminology that
people usually use
is sometimes called
relativism, or computation
relative to having
this extra information.
So P with an A oracle
is all of the language
that you can decide
in polynomial time
if you have an oracle
for A. Let's see.
Yeah.
Somebody's asking
me, is it really free
or does it cost one unit?
Even just setting up the oracle
and writing down the question
to the oracle is going to
take you some number of steps.
So you're not going to be
able do an infinite number
of oracle calls in zero time.
So charging one
step or zero steps,
not going to make a difference.
Because you still have to
formulate the question.
As I pointed out, P
with a SAT oracle--
so all the things you
do in polynomial time
with a SAT oracle includes NP.
Does it perhaps
include other stuff?
Or does it equal NP?
Would have been a good
check-in question,
but I'm not going to ask that.
In fact, it seems like it
contains other things too.
Because co-NP is also contained
within P, given a SAT oracle.
Because the SAT oracle
answer is both yes or no,
depending upon the answer.
So if the formula
is unsatisfiable,
the oracle is going to say
no, it's not in the language.
And now you can do the
complement of the SAT problem
as well.
The unsatisfiability problem.
So you can do all of
co-NP in the same way.
You can also define NP
relative to some oracle.
So all the things you can do
with a non-deterministic Turing
machine, where all
of the branches
have separately access.
And they can ask multiple
questions, by the way,
of the oracle.
Independently.
Let's do another, a little bit
of a more challenging example.
The MIN-FORMULA language,
which I hope you
remember from your homework.
So those are all of the
formulas that do not have
a shorter equivalent formula.
They are minimal.
You cannot make a smaller
formula that's equivalent that
gives you the same
Boolean function.
So you showed, for example, that
that language is in P space,
as I recall.
And there was some other--
you had another two
problems about that language.
The complement of the
MIN-FORMULA problem
is in NP with a SAT oracle.
So mull that over for a
second and then we'll see why.
Here's an algorithm, in NP
with a SAT oracle algorithm.
So in other words, now I
want to kind of implement
that strategy, which I argued
in the homework problem
was not legal.
But now that I have
the SAT oracle,
it's going to make it
possible where before it
was not possible.
So let's just understand
what I mean by that.
If I'm trying to do the
non minimal formulas,
namely the formulas that do have
a shorter equivalent formula.
I'm going to guess that
shorter formula, called psi.
The challenge before was testing
whether that shorter formula
was actually equivalent to phi.
Because that's not obviously
doable in polynomial time.
But the equivalence problem for
formulas is a co-NP problem.
Or if you like to think
about it the other way,
any formula in equivalence
is an NP problem,
because you just
have to-- the witness
is the assignment on
which they disagree.
So two formulas are equivalent
if they never disagree.
And so that's a co-NP problem.
A SAT oracle can
solve a co-NP problem.
Namely, the equivalence of the
two formulas, the input formula
and the one that you now
deterministically guessed.
And if it turns out that
they are equivalent,
a smaller formula is equivalent
to the input formula,
you know the input
formula is not minimal.
And so you can accept.
And if it gets
the wrong formula,
it turns out not
to be equivalent,
then you reject on that
branch of the non-determinism,
just like we did before.
And if the formula really was
minimal, none of the branches
is going to find a shorter
equivalent formula.
So that's why this problem here
is in NP with a SAT oracle.
So now we're going to try
to investigate this on my--
we're getting near the
end of the lecture.
We're going to look at
problems like, well,
suppose I compare
P with a SAT oracle
and NP with a SAT oracle.
Could those be the same?
Well, there's reasons to
believe those are not the same.
But could there be any
A where P with A oracle
is the same as NP
with an A oracle?
It seems like no, but
actually that's wrong.
There is a language, there
are languages for which
NP with that oracle
and P with that oracle
are exactly the same.
And that actually is an
interest-- it's not just
a curiosity, it actually
has relevance to strategies
for solving P versus NP.
Hopefully I'll be able
to have time to get to.
Can we think of an
oracle like a hash table?
I think hashing is somehow
different in spirit.
I understand there's
some similarity there,
but I don't see the--
hashing is a way of finding sort
of a short name for objects,
which has a variety
of different purposes
why you might want to do that.
So I don't really
think it's the same.
Let's see, an oracle
question, OK, let's see.
How do we use SAT oracle to
solve whether two formulas are
equivalent?
OK, this is getting
back to this point.
How can we use a SAT oracle to
solve whether two formulas are
equivalent?
Well, we can use a SAT oracle
to solve any NP problem,
because it's reducible to SAT.
In other words--
P with a SAT oracle
contains all of NP,
so you have to make sure
you understand that part.
If you have the clique
problem, you can reduce.
If I give you a clique problem,
which is an NP problem,
and I want to use the oracle
to test if the formula--
if the graph has a clique,
I reduce that problem
to a SAT problem using
the Cook-Levin theorem.
And knowing that a
clique of a certain size
is going to correspond to having
a formula which is satisfiable,
now I can ask the oracle.
And if I can do NP problems,
I can do co-NP problems,
because P is a
deterministic class.
Even though it has an oracle,
it's still deterministic.
It can invert the answer.
Something that non-deterministic
machines cannot necessarily do.
So I don't know, maybe that's--
let's move on.
So there's an oracle
where P to the A
equals NP to the A, which
kind of seems kind of amazing
at some level.
Because here's an oracle where
the non-determinism-- if I
give you that oracle,
non-determinism doesn't help.
And it's actually a
language we've seen.
It's TQBF.
Why is that?
Well, here's the whole proof.
If I have NP with a TQBF oracle.
Let's just check
each of these steps.
I claim I can do that with a
non-deterministic polynomial
space machine, which no
longer has an oracle.
The reason is that, if
I have polynomial space,
I can answer questions about
TQBF without needing an oracle.
I have enough space just to
answer the question directly
myself.
And I use my
non-determinism here
to simulate the non-determinism
of the NP machine.
So every time the NP machine
branches non-deterministically,
so do I. Every time
one of those branches
asks the oracle a
TQBF question, I just
do my polynomial space algorithm
to solve that question myself.
But now NPSPACE equals
PSPACE by Savitch's theorem.
And because TQBF
is PSPACE complete,
for the very same reason
that a SAT oracle allows
me to do every NP
problem, a TQBF problem
allows me to do
every PSPACE problem.
And so I get NP contained
within P for a TQBF oracle.
And of course, you get the
containment the other way
immediately.
So they're equal.
What does that have to do with--
somebody said--
well, I'll just--
I don't want to run out of time.
So I'll take any
questions at the end.
What does this got to do
with the P versus NP problem?
OK, so this is a very
interesting connection.
Remember, we just showed
through a combination
of today's lecture and
yesterday's lecture,
and I guess Thursday's
lecture, that this problem,
this equivalence problem,
is not in PSPACE,
and therefore it's not in P,
and therefore it's intractable.
That's what we just did.
We showed it's complete
for a class, which
is provably outside of P,
provably bigger than P.
That's the kind
of thing we would
like to be able to do
to separate P and NP.
We would like to show that
some other problem is not
in P. Some other
problem is intractable.
Namely, SAT.
If we could do SAT,
then we're good.
We've solved P and NP.
So we already have an example
of being able to do that.
Could we use the same method?
Which is something people
did try to do many years ago,
to show that SAT is not in P.
So what is that method really?
The guts of that method really
comes from the hierarchy there.
That's where you were actually
proving problems that are hard.
You're getting this problem
with through the hierarchy
construction that's
provably outside of PSPACE.
And outside of P.
That's a diagonalization.
And if you look carefully
at what's going on there--
so we're going to
say, no, we're not
going to be able to solve
SAT, show SAT's outside of P
in the same way.
And the reason is,
suppose we could.
Well the hierarchy theorems
are proved by diagonalization.
What I mean by that is that
in the hierarchy theorem,
there's a machine D, which is
simulating some other machine,
M. To remember what's
going on there,
remember that we
made a machine which
is going to make its language
different from the language
of every machine that's
running with less space
or with less time.
That's how D was defined.
It wants to make sure its
language cannot be done in less
space.
So it makes sure that its
language is different.
It simulates the machines
that use less space,
and does something
different from what they do.
Well, that simulation--
if we had an oracle,
if we're trying to
show that if we provide
both a simulator and the
machine being simulated
with the same oracle, the
simulation still works.
Every time the machine you're
simulating asks a question,
the simulator has
the same oracle
so it can also ask
the same question,
and can still do the simulation.
So in other words, if you
could prove P different from NP
using basically a
simulation, which
is what a diagonalization
is, then you
would be able to prove
that P is different from NP
for every oracle.
So if you can prove P different
from NP by a diagonalization,
that would also
immediately prove
that P is different from
NP for every oracle.
Because the argument is
transparent to the oracle.
If you just put the oracle
down, everything still works.
But-- here is the big
but, it can't be that--
we know that P A is--
we know this is false.
We just exhibit an oracle
for which they're equal.
It's not the case that
P is different from NP
for every oracle.
Sometimes they're
equal, for some oracles.
So something that's
just basically a very
straightforward diagonalization,
something that's
at its core is a
diagonalization,
is not going to be
enough to solve P and NP.
Because otherwise it
would prove that they're
different for every oracle.
And sometimes they're not
different, for some oracles.
That's an important insight
for what kind of a method
will not be adequate to
prove P different from NP.
And this comes up all the time.
People who propose hypothetical
solutions that they're trying
to show P different from NP.
One of the very first
things people ask is, well,
would that argument still work
if you put an oracle there.
Often it does, which points
out there was a flaw.
Anyway, last check in.
So this is just a little test
of your knowledge about oracles.
Why don't we-- in our
remaining minute here.
Let's say 30 seconds.
And then we'll do
a wrap on this,
and I'll point out
which ones are right.
Oh boy, we're all over
the place on this one.
You're liking them all.
Well, I guess the ones that
are false are lagging slightly.
OK, let's conclude.
Did I give you
enough time there?
Share results.
So, in fact--
Yeah, so having an
oracle for the complement
is the same as having an oracle.
So this is certainly true.
NP SAT equal coNP
SAT, we have no reason
to believe that
would be true, and we
don't know it to be true.
So B is not a good choice
and that's the laggard here.
MIN-FORMULA, well, is in
PSPACE, and anything in PSPACE
is reducible to TQBF, so
this is certainly true.
And same thing for NP with
TQBF and coNP with TQBF.
Once you have TQBF, you're
going to get all of PSPACE.
And as we pointed out, this
is going to be equal as well.
So why don't we end here.
And I think that's
my last slide.
Oh no, there's my summary here.
This is what we've done.
And I will send you
all off on your way.
How does the interaction
between the Turing
machine and the oracle look?
Yeah, I didn't define exactly
how the machine interacts
with an oracle.
You can imagine
having a separate tape
where it writes
the oracle question
and then goes into a
special query state.
You can formalize
it however you like.
They're all going to be-- any
reasonable way of formalizing
it is going to come up with
the same notion in the end.
It does show that P with a
TQBF oracle equals PSPACE.
Yes, that is correct.
Good point.
Why do we need the
oracle to be TQBF?
Wouldn't SAT also work because
it could solve any NP problem?
So you're asking, does
P with a SAT oracle
equal NP with a SAT oracle?
Not known.
And believed not to be
true, but we don't have
a compelling reason for that.
No one has any idea
how to do that.
Because, for example, we showed
the complement of MIN-FORMULA
is in NP with a SAT oracle.
But no one knows how to do--
because there's sort of two
levels of non-determinism
there.
There's guessing
the smaller formula,
and then guessing again
to check the equivalence.
And they really can't be
combined, because one of them
is sort of an exist
type guessing,
the other one is kind of
a for all type guessing.
No one knows how to do
that in polynomial time
with a SAT oracle.
Generally believed that
they're not the same.
In the check-in,
why was B false?
B is the same question.
Does NP with a SAT oracle
equal coNP with a SAT oracle?
I'm not saying it's false,
it's just not known to be true.
It doesn't follow from anything
that we've shown so far.
And I think that would
be something that--
well, I guess it
doesn't immediately
imply any famous open problem.
I wouldn't
necessarily expect you
to know that it's an
unsolved problem, but it is.
Could we have oracles
for undecidable language?
Absolutely.
Would it be helpful?
Well, if you're trying to
solve an undecidable problem,
it would be helpful.
But people do study that.
In fact, the original concept
of oracles was presented,
was derived in the
computability theory.
And a side note, you can
talk about reducibility.
No, I don't want
to even go there.
Too complicated.
What is not known to be true?
What is not known to be true
is that NP with a SAT oracle
equals coNP with a SAT oracle,
or equals P with a SAT oracle.
Nothing is known except the
obvious relations among those.
Those are all unknown, and just
not known to be true or false.
Is NP with a SAT
oracle equal to NP?
Probably not.
NP with a SAT oracle, for
one thing, contains coNP.
Because it's even more powerful.
We pointed out that P with
a SAT oracle contains coNP.
And so NP with a SAT oracle is
going to be at least as good.
And so it's going
to contain coNP.
And so, probably not
going to be equal to
NP unless shockingly
unexpected things
happen in our complexity world.